have you ever been to japan before i
have i've been there twice i went there
uh
god i don't know time anymore but like
maybe i think it was like right before
pandemic maybe like the year before
right and the year before that so i did
a trip to korea and japan
and was in korea for a week than tokyo
for a week um and that was with like uh
my wife and uh my my mom and my brother
and then the next year around the exact
same time both fall time i went to tokyo
again with some friends right uh i would
love to go outside of tokyo like you
know osaka kyoto like yeah yeah but
mainly i've just done tokyo what'd you
do when you were there
oh you know weeb [ __ ]
well like the first time i went it was
mainly
just my mom and uh was there you know we
did a lot of temples and yeah uh
traditional stuff traditional stuff
although i did take her to akihabara
she was like what the hell is this did
you say
yeah did you take her to a maid cafe i
did not uh because i have dignity but uh
i um was
so
like it was very surreal seeing her
react to
yeah
let's see what else did i do uh like
knock on broadway
yeah yeah that's the way yeah yeah um
i'm a big disney guy so tokyo disney c
um
uh other than that like just
going around like um
different areas like ikebukuro and stuff
like that and yeah just
checking stuff out did you play uh the
love life games while you were in there
no i didn't what i did end up doing was
uh a ton of crane games okay i ended up
getting like tons of [ __ ] through the
crane games and yeah that became my
thing nice yeah nice you do play against
each other yeah you got a chance yeah
yeah i hear you're really good
i'm not good i'm just tenacious
he's only good because he's done like
six videos yeah
i spent way more money than anyone
should have spent about like six
thousand dollars now on crane games you
know you would hope that
you would be good you literally like pay
to win right
what is the best thing you wanted a
green game oh definitely um i got this
uh it was like a
really nicely made lucario plush okay
that's holding like uh like one of the
pokemon fruits but it's like you know
when you get a plush sometimes you pick
it out of the thing you're like whoa
this is just anemic you feel like
there's there's stuff inside but it's
like it's like they didn't care where it
was yeah like the stuffing is all over
the place it's just a really really nice
quality plush and i would easily like
see it at the pokemon store whatever for
like 60 bucks 50 bucks yeah it's really
nice and you could get it for like 20
pretty reasonably nice if you're good
yeah now even if you're bad you can just
be like suma yeah
come over like right right because they
don't know you know the staff don't know
how long you've been playing for
that's polite you know they just they
just
assume you're not taking the piss and
not calling them over after one yeah
which i don't do
which i'm sure they'll respond to
willingly anyway they would like if you
just took one shot yeah and
maybe actually because they they'd know
if you've moved it a bunch right yeah
with certain claws they don't know yeah
yeah because if you pick up something
and it just flops over somewhere they're
not going to know it's your first time
yeah yeah with the ones we've got to
shimmy it yeah suck
yeah you can't choose them you have to
just do it but that they'd know if you
would yeah
now that i've been in japan for a while
i'd like i was never
like deeply into the crane game culture
just because
like obviously you want to win the prize
but i feel like you get like cooler
figurines and cooler accessories just by
buying it you know
yeah but there are some exclusive stuff
that is only for crane games right which
you can but you you can buy it because
yeah yeah but like do you think it's
like do you think it's like cooler than
what you can actually find
in store in like other places i'll say
this for me like for me i don't ever buy
plushies ever right that's not something
i do actually that's true but in a crane
game i'm like but if i win this
then it's [ __ ] great
i can get behind the plushie i remember
like winning the chainsaw man plushie in
your video that was actually
legitimately cool that's probably like
the only thing that i kept oh i've got
the pen pen as well
oh yeah oh yeah
i feel like crane game figurines like
you know you know like they look like
crane game figurines yeah they're pretty
basic yeah they're very figurines are
okay i do make i don't know if you do
this but when i pursue a crane game it
does have to be something at least
relevant to my interests yeah like i do
have a friend who like just does them to
like get
like victory yeah he just gives away the
[ __ ] but for me it's like it's got to be
something i like actually care about
getting something you actually want to
keep yeah yeah yeah if it was me on my
own no videos or no cameras or anything
then yeah that would help i would do it
but on camera you're like well i got to
win stuff
and i don't want to play the machines
that are hard yeah so i'm going to play
the ones that i know i can win and then
sometimes you get a good plush and you
get it in an amount of turns you're like
this was a steal i got this for a steal
yeah i got this in 10 and this
definitely costs 20 bucks in retail yeah
i'm a genius
i'm gaming the system yeah
that's what it feels amazing yeah like
you had a fun time you won and then you
also have a prize for cheaper than you
would have paid for it yeah but you also
never would have bought that product yes
because so because you've done the crane
game video with conor as well how long
did it take for you to just kind of like
be [ __ ] sick of it because like the
first 15 minutes i remember i think it
was like after half an hour i was just
like how is this gonna like it was a
great video but like i remember drinks
during filming i'm like this is gonna be
like because it's like every like 15
like 20 minutes you think you're
starting to get it yeah and then
something happens where you're just like
never mind i don't know how to do this
now
yeah i know nothing yeah we just give
people a budget and it normally takes
like three hours of playing green games
sure and uh that's a long time to play
it's like a long time because after the
first hour yeah like you said you start
to just start to get really miserable
yeah yeah you're also carrying all the
stuff yeah yeah yeah you got to remove
because we have like a suction cup to
attach to it yeah it's just it's a whole
ordeal unless you're chris and you only
win one thing yeah yeah yeah
some people aren't very good we had any
person who actually enjoyed doing it and
wanted to keep doing it was kaho right
but calhoun yeah she's really good yeah
she's good at themselves yeah but like
i've been incited to everyone because
normally like with our previous guests
right there's been this like joke where
the guests are just like oh we're gonna
talk about anime and we kind of like
look at each other and laugh right
because uh we generally talk a lot less
about anime than people think that we
talk about it but
you loki have like a [ __ ] amazing
taste in anime
like i don't know like i just i just
gotta say man i just i can't remember
what video it was where like you had to
like say what your favorite anime were
but i remember you going down the list
and i'm like damn you got some good
[ __ ] shows
you were raiding waifus i think
which one yeah out of the many videos
think yeah i i watch i was like okay
okay yeah it's got good taste remember
when this guy busts that oh yeah i
really like legends of the galactic
heroes that's that's that's how you
know you're the real one oh you know
that's that's so you've seen all of it
huh you've seen all of it
yeah yeah yeah i have seen
70 episodes i've i've still got like the
last last few hours to go through but
yeah it's it's [ __ ] incredible it's
all right it's amazing and you rarely
get you kind of look so lost right now
but i've voiced in like one of the
dubs or something you in the in the new
one right yeah yeah me too yeah yeah i
feel like every everyone digs
there's so many characters there's so
many verses like i can't get every voice
actor what did your guy do in it uh he
was uh i think he was someone in a bar
overhearing something and talking about
covert uh
it was no it was two of them they're
from different factions and they were
arguing but like very discreetly were
you on yongwin lee's side or reinhardt
i was on the one where you don't know
[ __ ] about the characters you play
i rocked up and i was like why don't you
watch the shows you voiced
legend of the gladiator is an exception
it's too [ __ ] long
it's good though it's it's it's only
i mean even though i haven't finished
the original yeah but i really the i
think the remake's also really good i
hear it's good yeah i haven't seen it i
haven't seen the remake